wollen wir herzlich willkommen zum
kontakt eventuell ist die tonqualität
ein bisschen praktisch haben wir heute
einfach mal einen anderen platz gesucht
über ein bisschen etwas zu reden heute
also das wird jetzt ein heftiges thema
wollt euch anschauen möchte da so etwas
alten bisschen weil ich mich einfach mal
zum kenner gesetzt habe es halt einfach
dem grund weil meine eltern gerade in
england sind und ich bin hier und muss
eigentlich fürs abi lernen alles
mögliche und hab mir gedacht dass ich
wenn man anderenorts falls man in
zimmern deswegen habe ich mich einfach
im keller ein gesetz geregelt und
aufgemalt ist es halt halt alles ein
bisschen deswegen habe ich auch extra
ein neues niveau hier mitgebracht
ich hoffe dass halt nicht ganz so viel
aber auch wenn es halt dann ist es der
effekt den ich auch so ein bisschen
damit über bringen möchte und zwar
möchte ich heute bei meinen schlimmsten
albtraum
ihr wisst ja dass der kontakte was ist
wo ich jetzt nicht immer sachen zusammen
schon ein und alles ist kann auch mal
sein dass ich so etwas mache wie
longboard paaren habe ich letztes mal
gemacht oder dass ich auch einfach die
woche zusammenfasst und alles ist total
vielseitig sein sonntag und heute möchte
ich halt einfach mal in meinen
schlimmsten albtraum reden und euch das
ganze so ein bisschen anschaulichen und
da haben bevor ich jetzt anfange bevor
ihr das jetzt hört schreibt mir nochmal
eurem schlimmsten albträume kommentare
es war das irgendwie dass ihr von ihm
verfolgt wurde
dass ihr nachfolger schwimmen schwimmen
oder dass hier eine wanne voller spinnen
bad oder das mg eure familie getötet
wurde da keine ahnung das feuer
schwimmzeit von ihren verwandten in die
kommentare
und ich würde sagen jetzt geht es los
und ich fange jetzt mal an über meinen
schlimmsten dafür erzählt bleibt
bestehen lässt dass so viele das ist
unglaublich ist einfach ich habe ich bin
nicht krank ist rings um das thema
süchtig bei mir war es halt so als ich
irgendwie neun oder zehn oder elf die
daumen in der wm war hatte die zeit wo
man nicht cool geführt hat wenn man so
film ab 16 oder 18 also wenn man das
noch nicht wirklich durfte und dadurch
haben die einst guckt was halt da der
film ist ab 16 das ist halt so eine
nachmachen können oder die parodie von
allen möglichen woche finden die zu der
zeit gab
da waren dann solche filme weil die
screen und keine ahnung ich weiß was du
letzten sommer getan hast und ganz viele
sachen die wurden darin halt so wie
alles gerne die einst kennen der
krankheit auch
dieser screen was ich ja ganz schön
kaputt halt auch screen drin parodiert
und das war halt alles ein bisschen
jetzt war halt alles ein bisschen witzig
dargestellt
aber dieser dieses in dem moment als ich
das geguckt aber das ganze für mich auch
einfach nur ein ganz normaler film und
wird sie zum anschauen und die nächte
danach habe ich auch gar nicht mehr
nachgedacht werden ganz normal ab in
denen uns angeschaut haben nur in der
vierten nacht nachdem ich diese filme
guckt das hatte ich auf einmal voll die
albträume von diesem scheiß trio typen
der eigentlich total dämlich dargestellt
für den scary 1 aber ich hätte einfach
so krassen albtraum kann ich euch jetzt
einfach erzählen also bevor ich damit
jetzt wirklich anfangen ich rede hier
viel drum rum halt erstmal ist dass
dieser traum nicht jahre lang getestet
hat mehr oder weniger als kraftvoll
kraft dass ihr euch das eigentlich so
erzähle aber es war halt echt bei mir so
dass ich dann nächtelang nicht schlafen
gehen wollte nur eingeschlafen bin weil
ich dann irgendwie vorher drei stunden
schon im bett lag und total umgebaut was
alles sonst hab ich halt immer so viel
angst davor dass plattformen sich geholt
er hat sich noch keiner geholt ich hier
nicht passieren also mit meiner track
airlines mitbürger ich erzähler
standorten von metro band und zwar lag
ich dann so ein bett und bin dann
eingeschlafen als ich schlafe immer
relativ später ich brauche immer noch 20
minuten werde ich nicht mit gewinn um
einzuschlafen
ich lag dann halt ein bett eingeschlafen
und dann war ich hin nimmt in einer
riesigen halle hat ca sogar halt wie
hier in dieser halle und es war jetzt
nochmal volles lager alle daran halten
baumstämme und verarbeitet das holz sind
dass es auch eigentlich dass ich das
jetzt alles noch passieren lassen kann
also das ist zwar zur hälfte meines
lebens denn das war als ich neun war
dass es neun jahre hier und ich kann
trotzdem ich weiß es noch genau alles
wie alles da aufgebaut bei den trucks
kräftig fakt ist auf jeden fall ich war
dann in dieser schweiz halle drin und
das behalten was macht ihr da alle es
war irgendwie der dritte inter das
dritte untergeschoss gegend wieder das
war nicht nach alle die auf dem offen ob
er die oberfläche stationen die in biel
darunter war
und da war es halt auch relativ klar das
war vor mitternacht auf einmal das war
halt da drin ist was total heller das
war nicht immer dunkel und ich hatte
angst das sieht man irgendwelche kommt
oder so plötzlich richtig hält das ist
genau so wie wir jetzt diese software
hingegen schaltet einfach nur richtig
komisches licht und ich dachte dann
einfach cool was mache ich hier was soll
ich hier was soll dieser traum als ich
wusste natürlich dass es den frauen
denken immer dass es realität ist und
auf einmal als ich lag da hier die auf
dem boden
dann habe ich mich so aufgerichtet und
guckt also nach vorne dann hab ich zur
stream gesehen der auf einmal hier so
gegenüberstand dieser komischen maske
also der zeit der darin keine regung
hatte da so ein messer in der hand und
kamen so ganz langsam mich auf mich
zugelaufen für ganz lange sache so ganz
normal gegangen und ich natürlich total
hand wenn man denkt ist es realität man
wird auch ein typ mit messer und legen
so eine komische maske steckt vor allem
ich rutsche nach hinten lauf so weg
versucht zu laufen laufe ich die stelle
vor dem wettkampf locker messe wie groß
sie alle über 30 20 meter vorsprung
würde ich sagen
lauft dann auf so eine treppe zu wir
wollten diese treppe hochgehen und noch
die treppe hoch zehn stufen oder so
sondern
die zinke und die tür verschlossen ich
glaube treffen wieder runter der typ den
die drei meter vor mir oder so nicht
zustimmen so grad bei der gab es mit dem
messer zugestochen hat zattoo stehen
sollen inzwischen ist auch ein kurs
macht und lauft einfach hin sonst
fahrstuhl ein und da war dann halt so
ein fahrstuhl halten den mann immer so
offen dann wenn ich das drin und dann
kannst du erdgeschoss drücken
die sicherheit und so ich stehe dann in
diesem fahrstuhl drücke auf erdgeschoss
der typ kommt mir also spielen kommt
näher auf diese fahrstuhltür zu zwei
meter davor kommt immer näher ich durchs
erdgeschoss fischer schnelligkeit drauf
und dann auch wenn man die tür geht's
lang grenzen so dann so langsam werde
ich bin kommt einfach durch die tür ein
und spricht dann halt einfach ab während
ich in diesem paar studenten also das
war es auch schon das ist jetzt
vielleicht nicht so krah verdeckt man
sich einfach okay dann warst auch da
müsste verschwitzte war es ein alptraum
basta
aber für mich war das einfach so dass
mich dieses ereignis so lange geprägt
hat das war kurz vor halloween hat dann
irgendwann als dann irgendwann der
scream maske um die 40 auch irgendwie
wieder so voll
ich hab da nicht geweint und so habe ich
habe dann dazu verpflichtet zu stellen
ich weiß dass einige jetzt lachen werden
aber irgendwie dieser traum der hat mich
dann mehreren wochen monate geprägt das
war echt so krasse staatsführungen das
war richtig heftig keiner wusste davon
beweglichkeit
aber also jetzt merken dann lache ich
mich dabei geld aus aber es war ein ganz
normaler frauen aber dieses dass man
diese sonderlauf behinderung hat es ich
hab keine lauf reden
ein ganzer wald auch umsatz liegt aber
im traum finde es manchmal wenn man dann
schnell laufen will da ist man richtig
langsam und das habe ich halt da das
nicht so vor ihm weglaufen wollte aber
ich war trotzdem voll langsam und der
kommt so ganz langsam hinter mir und ich
mich damit zu machen also das war auf
jeden fall richtig krasser momentan ist
egal es hätte ja freunde das war es mit
diesem konzert auch schon wieder ich
hoffe ich hab's befahren ich habe man
versucht einfach so ein bisschen was
anderes zu machen wir wollen dass
hingesetzt habe ein bisschen anders geht
das video geschnitten also nicht
wirklich anders schneiden ist immer noch
der gleiche gewesen aber ich hab's
versucht dadurch ein bisschen besser
rüber zu bringen wenn die auch schon mal
albträume hat oder so einen ähnlichen
form hatten auf jeden fall eine
kommentare mich wird das brennend
interessieren was ihre freunde hatte bzw
als albträume empfindet wenn es euch
gefallen hat in ihr lächeln mehr von
solchen konten haben wollt oder die
allgemeinen die serie feierte
hier kommt das eine positive wertung gab
jetzt euch nicht gefällt die negative
bewertung ist eure sache mit ihr
entscheiden hier dass ich hier bewertet
und sonst würde ich sagen euch noch ein
wunderschönes fachwissen und seine waffe
und schoss